ils ont fait un tout petit scoop et il
joue le rôle d'un hétérosexuel donc
c'est génial c'est un vrai rôle de
composition
est-ce qu'il peut embrasser entrer parce
que ça fait bien l'été ont validé
[Musique]
on l'a alors elle est déjà là mais did
we made you mais qu'est ce que c'est que
c'est oui il est amour les instincts
[Applaudissements]
housse avec benoît à des mystères de
l'amour mais sachez que max un rôle
important dans la série 24 heures chrono
et es14 ouzou et béjaïa
[Applaudissements]
je me remet difficilement de cette 10 e
j
[Applaudissements]
vous serrez crime
magnifique
c'est donc tout est dans l'ordre
j'ai cru j'ai cru voir un steak tartare
c'était mon idée c'était bastareaud